so my introduction I haven't given you
my introduction today I'm a first time I
actually at free code camp and already
giving a talk how good is that
and I'm gonna talk about DevOps it's not
really coding I want to show much code
but I want to show you something or talk
about the culture of DevOps a little bit
and I see many developers in every day
and I don't see many companies that get
DevOps right and it's very a very
important topic and I think everybody
should know something about it first
thank you thanks we accelerate I think
it's really great because we are
starting to do more and more meetups
here in this place and I think it's good
to have we accelerate here and giving us
the opportunity to to enjoy this venue
just a few links I'll probably put the
slides online and I like to do things
and references first because otherwise
nobody will see them anymore in
afterwards introduction Who am I I'm a
software developer for 10 years or not
really a starter and currently my
favorite language is golang I do a lot
of Perl and I do typescript
mostly because I have to I'm not too
good at it and I started off as a
sysadmin some what 15 years ago I
thought about it yesterday when I wrote
my slides and was sysadmin at the
University of Economics in Austria and
so I had some 20,000 users we had to
administer and you guess probably there
wasn't much manual intervention possible
doing that so we had to do a lot of
coding so I switched to becoming
yourself to a developer when I actually
quit the University and
I'm quite an expert at causing and
fixing disasters causing is easy but it
doesn't happen as much anymore
and fixing is okay take some time and
experience but I'm pretty relaxed with
these situations I get dumped into my
name is Klaus eater forgot to say that
usually I have an ich somewhat combined
with coqui coqui is very quickly taking
in all the public websites so look for
derivative that that's my Twitter handle
it's easy to remember and sorry for the
layout because my slides got messed up
when I arrived here they were all
written in markdown and I should have
some plugin that tells them to HTML
converts them to HTML but something
happened so I had to rewrite some macro
in my editor just quickly make HTML from
my slide so for that they are pretty
beautiful and I'm a total dope it's yes
so please just get used to those slides
and they won't get prettier than that
some buzzwords not important just some
get the feeling if you have any
questions just ask them okay I don't
like having all the questions afterwards
because maybe you don't remember and you
might have okay okay sorry
no questions hate you and no casings
DevOps the initial setting how did we
find that DevOps or how was it incubated
or whatever there was sis admins and
there were developers and there were
business requirements and sales people
and each of those silos actually hated
each other or I think they still do more
or less but something is happening so
the two sides that were the most opposed
sides were the scissored means and the
developers and and I'm both so
it's easy for me to to tell you this
it gave me hard times quite often sorry
for the small funds but that's my CSS
skills okay
so then there's a there's a conflict in
sysadmin and development as a developer
you always check for the latest library
and you always want to have the latest
and greatest tools and try this and try
it try that some AI or whatever and as
it says admin you usually are being paid
for sitting in the back room and just
keeping everything stable and as soon as
something moves a little bit you just
bash it down so it doesn't move anymore
and so those two groups are somewhat not
in sync and someone someday just said
well you know we could work together and
at the time I was in at that university
I had told you about there was I think
that there was the seed of DevOps coming
up that there were configuration engines
starting to get bigger and bigger and it
was the very early I think puppet wasn't
no puppet work there was no puppet at
that time but there was cfengine at the
time and and people started scripting
infrastructure and and people stopped
actually doing things manually the bad
thing is I still see a lot of people
manually intervening with their
computers and the what are the goals of
depa DevOps we just want to keep a
constant flow through the technology
value stream so so what does that mean
it's in the old days you always had
infrastructure and you had development
and those two didn't work well together
and especially in bigger companies there
was software development and software
development cycles were months or years
long and then there was an integration
phase and that hand
over the software project to the UPS
people which are system administrators
and they try to figure out how to
actually get a project working and
running and stable running and that
pushed the launch date of every product
further and further away and I still see
that in many startup companies now also
I mean people are developing and
developing and then there's release day
and they find out Oh we'd never thought
about infrastructure where we actually
want to run the project but it works on
my machine I see that quite a lot and
it's it's a lot of about culture to
actually put together all the team and
make everybody participate from from the
team so it's not only developers or C's
admins but it's also the marketing
people it's the icon designers it's the
I don't know CSS people are those
developers yeah let's say and it's the
sales people that mustn't sell things
that that can't be developed or
everybody needs to be in a team and this
is a bit what DevOps is about also the
thing I explained before they zero day
one day to day and the product has to
run all the time
and yeah basically work together in all
of phases of its life DevOps is about
culture automation lean measurement and
sharing these are the key points of of
DevOps let's go through them culture is
something I see a lot in technologies
there's that boss and boss shouts at
everybody and this is this bone I mean
this delete two results in short-term
but people leave and people join
companies people leave managers and it
doesn't really lead to a good team and
to a good work experience and what we
really want to impose
is get blame free learning experiment
and experimentation framework so we all
make mistakes we make a lot of mistakes
probably but the only difference between
between a well-established developer or
a DevOps guy or whatever and and the
beginner is the number of mistakes they
have made that that's the only
difference
and yeah
this means we really we do have volatile
in environments anything we do changes
all the time and because we do
experiment everybody is allowed to
experiment everybody is allowed to bring
in new technologies we change everything
all the time but still we managed to
reduce risk I'll explain that later how
we managed to work that out we try to
have no more silos and which is actually
fun because we start actually talking to
people there were some people who came
here to talk to others this is true for
every company the developers can start
talking to marketing people and the C's
admins can start talking to sales people
and actually this is an interesting
thought it should be it should be a
baseline in every company anyway we all
shared a responsibility for our finished
product we all earned money that the
company earns and we all have to bring
in money and we all important for the
company so of course we share
responsibility and it's important that
everybody knows that everybody is
responsible for having the product out
and autonomous teams is just because we
share responsibility we are able to
actually decide things on our we don't
need to ask the boss all the time
Automation
there's a I think on the first slide I
had those thank you things there's a
book it
it's a long book and it gets a bit
boring after a while but it's the sre
book of by google i don't know if you
know a site reliability engineering and
but they have amazing chapters that are
really good and one of them is about
automation and toil especially and I
like the term it's it was created in
Google I think and it means that
anything you do and anything you do more
than once that can be automated must be
automated and this is one of the really
basic thoughts in DevOps so whatever can
be triggered by whatever matrix needs to
be automatically automatically solved
because otherwise what you might see you
have many many busy people that do the
same thing over and over and again and
this is the worst that can happen okay
so anything that's manual repetitive and
automatable tactically important for our
company has no value at all that's very
important you know the the webserver
that needs to be restarted because
whatever we have bad code and we have
mem leaks or whatever and the sysadmin
goes to and look logs into that web
server SSH is in there and and just
types in nginx restart that's a waste of
time you can automate that you can just
watch memory and just kill that thing
and and it'll have the same effect it's
not a solution it's not a long-term
solution but it it will take away work
from the sysadmin
who can then develop a better solution
and probably reduce memory leaks okay
and doing this removing toil all the
time is a huge resource saver and and
imagine I mean Google did the sre teams
they are not allowed they are not even
allowed to do more than 50% toil in
they're their work time which is I mean
think of your scissored means what they
do all the time
least of them are actually living that
well there is that term lean eliminate
waste amplify learning decide as late as
possible deliver as fast as possible
that's all the they I mean I hope you
you live by those standards now I'm
empowered a team build integrity and see
the whole see the old is I think the
only thing I really have to explain more
even as developer or sysadmin
or whatever person they were in whatever
topic you are in just see what the goal
is and and always know what is my
company doing and what are we actually
trying to get out to our customer it's
very important to to see that all the
time is what I am doing
currently important for my customers
does it actually give value to the
customer instrumentation anything and
this gets forgotten by the most I don't
know how many startups are here I just
saw some everybody who's making new
products and many people have started
new products and they forget about
measurements and instrumentation and
this should be one of the core built-ins
in every product that you create
if you don't instrument everything you
do and if you don't have graphs for
every whatever information you you
generate in your software you will feel
a DevOps because if you can't measure
things and if you can't analyze things
you can't react and of course a human
being can react and I have a very good
feeling about who I don't know I think
the system is in a bad state and I have
to do something but if you don't have
numbers to prove and if you don't have
numbers to analyze
you can automate these things here you
see a graph from this is something
actually a marketing guy he created
these graphs we are generating all the
the information and the marketing guy
just clicks together it's some health
whatever tool and and they can just see
okay how do the numbers perform did we I
don't know we had some release and
numbers went down and then other
releases and we try to to get to release
the numbers up again and just just to
show you that anything we do and
whatever whatever this is
registration verified verification
profile setup so so people that try to
register verify their profile and then
or change data in the their profile
which is important in this project
we just measure what they do so we have
the I call it the DevOps bretzel and if
you go to DevOps meetups nowadays you
see this brittle all the time and I just
wanted to show it to you it it's a
never-ending cycle of okay you release a
product you configured your monitor
monitoring okay you plan for the next
release you build you you create you
check the numbers again from monitoring
you package it release it and so on and
so on and on and that cycle goes forever
and now the testimony I'm a developer
okay DevOps is something that should
actually impact the whole company and I
don't know much about how marketing
people feel about it I mean I know that
they work in my team together with me
and and we have a good relationship but
I don't know what they feel about the
whole DevOps movement so what I can only
talk about is how software development
goes software operations
and how we execute it okay I don't
really care about the finance department
there's so much okay how do we live it
we use get or whatever revision control
system you you're using do whatever you
want but I mean I think everybody uses
get if you're not and I've seen that
recently in the last two years actually
company's not using it start using it
use some integration service everybody
knows what an integration services it's
an automated tool that takes your
product and puts it into production
it must be automated don't have someone
say ok should we release today maybe you
talked about releasing today but it must
be automated the whole integration and
releasing process must be such a non op
that you do it all the time you did all
the time and use build tools so however
you try to make your final product I
don't know if you do web design you
probably have some grunt or web pack or
whatever running automate that you can
have it running but if it needs any
parameters script that at least we have
built tools built into to get chain so
if I get pushed and the product gets
built and released I would recommend I
mean this is not an official statement
I'd recommend you use a cloud it doesn't
matter if you have your own cloud if you
have I don't know a service center and
2000 servers and and just run your cloud
find that that's fine but the concept of
cloud must be implemented so so probably
if you're in smaller companies use I
don't know a double years Google or
something like that
use provisioning tools for everything
you don't start naming service or
anything like that
the a a I'll come to that later and and
see your hardware as software okay so
don't don't name your hardware don't
don't know your hardware any more
abstracted make it software okay
continuous integration there's a great
article by Martin Fowler about it
Martin follow you all know Martin Fowler
he's I don't know and I can in ite I
take he writes articles did all of them
were like 15 pages long and quite quite
a read but always well well thought of
and well-designed and he look him up
Martin Fowler and read all his articles
it'll take you a month or so but it's
worth it and he says continuous
integration what's the base point
checkout main line main line is the
master branch yeah
develop a quick feature and I mean we
even have tools for if we have an issue
or ticket that we want to work on that
actually creates a branch named like
that ticket so everybody who works on
that same issue creates the same branch
name so we can share and interact with
that build test and merge fully
automated very often and always know
your code is running and failing or
broken builds don't make it to main line
so we have all that automated except for
the coding part we need to do that
unfortunately and we pushed into the
repo everything gets built I don't need
to type to build and merge and whatever
it all gets done by tooling and after a
minute I get an email if the build fails
other or pop up on my screen actually
and otherwise
my changes get merged into mainline and
are in this staging staging environment
continuous delivery deliver all the time
so what I've done before I coded I
merged it into mainline and now it's
about delivery and every successful
merge you see gets into that staging
environment so that we have a webpage
that has a total clone of everything we
do we can have multiple clones also but
but staging is the most important
preview it runs against a real clone of
the actual data and we have buttons for
for creative review promote the
production or rollback so there's no
manual intervention with anything we do
actually so what and these buttons can
be pressed by a marketing guy and this
is very important that it's not always
the developers that decide okay we can
go online no if all the tests pass and
if the product looks fine to the
marketing guys they are the ones that
wanted to feature of course they press
the button to to actually release that
feature if they don't press it I press
it yeah anybody can and so this is
standard deployments of each of those
what's that vertical lines are a
deployment and that standard for us that
we actually deploy all the time and then
you watch I don't know something happens
or doesn't happen and and so we always
mark everything that's the
instrumentation part I talked about you
need to know okay we had this code
running and it had this impact on our
customers so maybe we need to change
something or maybe that was a good
change and let's party by deploying so
often we keep things unstable but we
reduce risk if we deploy only once a
month or only once a year
half year then the deployment gets
really tough and now we just deploy and
everything is fine unless you do
disaster deployment like I did last week
where I blacked out for half an hour I
think the whole product but that was
very special didn't happen for years
actually because usually we have that
but this is also the experience nobody
shouted at me when that happened we just
found out okay what was the problem and
how do we fix it and how do we prevent
it from happening the next time
it was my mistake I did something wrong
but how can we prevent it in the future
and so what we want is that we actually
have the cue and it's running the the
pipeline is running and it says okay
sorry I can't continue something
something happened I don't know what
happened here but whatever and we are
safe we have way too many features to
test them all we've been working on this
product I didn't I think for nine years
or something and and it's just too many
features and sometimes we have long
workflows so we gather information and
we export it to different clients and
and and we improve the data we've
recycled it in and there's so many
workflows they take a while and and they
need to take a while and and we have
different performance it just can't test
everything and but we do have alerts for
every core business case so whatever
happens we know so we see we act we know
ok and and if we if we see we have a
problem and we don't have measurements
yet we act so we introduce measurements
instrumentation for that problem and in
the future we have something automated
for it and we have many alerts that
shouldn't trigger ok and we always know
exactly when which version of code was
online so we have our stats and we can
always say ok at that point in time we
had this revision running very important
I see that a lot
people don't know they just go to
service to get pull so that they think
they're advanced because they use get
they do get pull server restart have no
idea what happens and yeah we have much
better things to do than testing our
code manually so I don't want to browse
our website all the time and and then we
have products that I don't even want to
touch too much because I don't know I
think I just don't like them and it's
good to have that automated and we need
to detect the errors as fast as possible
and stop them from passing along the
value stream so even when I blacked out
last week
I knew it within seconds and that's very
important and you know so you can act
quickly and and fix things this is still
markdown syntax be very disciplined so
if you want to do that you and the whole
team must be very disciplined we we do
we create strict 12 factor apps we don't
ever do quick fixes even if I know ok I
could just log in and change that line
in nginx and and fix some I don't know
proxy path or something and it would
work we don't do it we create a fix we
patch we commit we release and that
always has to be this way and if a
broken commit exists in in in your tool
chain that's the most important part to
fix because as soon as you let your
tools down and you start to work around
the tools and manually install things
the whole system breaks yeah always use
tools and if you can do it you can
script it that that's my philosophy
whatever you do it is scriptable it
might be hard it might be hard to first
time it gets easier and easier ok and
very important is learn all the time I
read books all the time I read articles
all the time
there's not a single day I don't learn
something and I could say that for my
whole team nobody nobody ever lays these
down and says okay I know enough just
doesn't happen and communicate a lot I
mean it's easy for us we're we're less
than the two pizza team I eat one pizza
and but it's easy for us to communicate
otherwise we're also not in danger to
have designers because we are very close
together we're in still in one office
which is in one floor so it's not not a
big I don't know like único whatever
over there we have huge buildings and
and it's hard to communicate so for us
really communication is easy I want to
talk about failures things that did not
work I've worked at multiple companies
with multiple companies I've seen things
fail I failed I failed with my team I
saw teams fail after investing hundreds
of thousands of Euro in to DevOps what
doesn't work
being half committed doesn't work okay
either you do it or you don't do it
halfway cost a lot of money ansible or
scrip deployments on pet servers
everybody knows what the pet server is
it's one way you know the host name it's
a server you like and never have a
striver you like okay Vicki playbooks
four deployments and upgrades I see that
a lot people think they're so smart
because they have everything written
down in Vicki and they copy and paste
every line and then create a new project
how we uh got a new custom and creating
new customer takes quarter of an hour I
don't know the three hours I don't know
copy-paste all the lines from Vicki I
mean just script that or make make it
micro service that creates a new
customer strongly wired services doesn't
know
never work I mean we've fully migrated
to my micro service environments and
initially that the first migration
started with service a knows exactly
about service B and we can talk to each
other no it's like pet service it's just
pet software what didn't work using KVM
then or VMware in in our deployments so
for the software we were trying to
deploy it those virtualization
technologies work very well to abstract
hardware but they don't work well to
abstract
software for infrastructure yes but not
for the deployed product itself
delegating core services sorry to say
whoever outsourcing companies here the I
don't know DNA is hosting all these core
things that are needed for your product
you must do all that in-house
outsourcing software development didn't
work for us nobody can outsource a
philosophy and it's the main thing you
do if you if you do software and every
company does software nowadays and
everyday company mainly does IT nowadays
different aspects of IT but everybody
needs IT you can't outsource it
outsourcing C's admins very bad idea
taking responsibility away from people
we tried that with people who didn't
want to dev up and who didn't want to
work in that strategy so we said ok you
just fix that little issue and then you
commit it and we cover for the rest
doesn't work you unfortunately I have to
get rid of those people multiple git
repositories didn't work for us we have
a lot of I don't know that that company
is seven seven hundred makes of
source code and we have it all in in one
repo and it's fine with Kate nobody
cares and if you have multiple
repositories you have to work with get
sub modules and stuff doesn't work so
well just use one mono repo and we do
that everything you do must always be
code and all truth lies in the repo so
if I die today
it doesn't really matter because I mean
I wouldn't care and and otherwise
anything I've done even my talk which I
just rewrote isn't get anything not
committed has no value at all because it
can just be gone or broken or I don't
know you can't find it anymore
especially in case you run into a bus
and or you get hacked because we've got
that hacked server I want to see all you
want to change your infrastructure which
is the most important point I mean that
happens frequently or frequently every
few years you want to switch from one
provider to another one if you don't
have domain or anything actually
everything script scripted you won't be
able to make that move if you have to
manually set up infrastructure won't
work and thanks very much questions
[Applause]